welcome everybody today sri podcast live
today's episode is sponsored by honey
and Squarespace and viewers like you who
subscribe on Twitch prime you could
connect it it's so easy it's free money
um I mean I go over this every week
thanks guys today's guest is the
Canadian a record producer DJ musician
composer streamer car racer gamer
Renaissance man anything else
Renaissance man kind of a true
renaissance man if I'm being honest new
album is coming out where's the drop
tomorrow right
yeah that's really exciting thank you
I mean tomorrow's the 30th that comes
out on the 30th yeah that's really
exciting thank you for being here now
before we get too deep into our
conversation I know that your smoker did
I not say then was that a thing that
people only said like at the beginning
nobody really says deadmau5 they do they
soul do they do I don't care I think
it's just funny guy and then when I
started learning that nobody could
really get it right I started saying it
differently at different like events or
like that I'd say Jeff Maehl 5 deadmau5
I would I say hi this is deadmau5 and
then everyone would like Oh take that to
the bank you know
oh there was like 20 old pure chaos yeah
why did you choose the 5 instead of an S
we're kindred spirits in that regard we
have h3 or C on F net remember that I
yeah
IRC yeah yeah well chat yeah and then f
net you know you had f net down that or
whatever you know the different IRC
networks or stuff so I was on Afghan
mm-hmm and I used to be an hashtag
actionscript which was like flash coding
um for flash like back in the day and
it's early stuff so I used to hang out
there with like guys like Craig Keynes
and who later turned out to be like you
know the god of ASPR AFP flash morning
and stuff like big coder nerds and um so
I I don't I remember the context but I
changed my name too
deadmau5 MOU se but like you could only
have seven characters on that then so I
had to trim the last one then just put a
five that's just to save space kind of
thing so I wouldn't be thinking at the
time that you know when I start my
musical endeavors I'd be yeah do you
think that it's it's almost great in a
way though because it's more intriguing
it's more interesting right oh yeah and
I mean jay-z was taken otherwise you'd
be alright yeah
jay-z like in our case we were we wanted
to be he he which is our initials and he
sounds really stupid I'm glad all right
and although is that what it is yeah
because my name is Ethan Edward and elos
is Kela I was like h-cubed podcast that
would be cool I wish it was cubes H cute
what is it is cute we're cubed but
anyway so we did the threes and that's
much cooler than hehe mm-hmm so there
you go
Jesse's a mother of invention as I was
saying your smoker and and that's you
know I'm not here to try to like change
you or anything I just think that
there's there are people say more
organic
maybe healthier ways to smoke I don't
know I'll let you decide but we have a
we have a vape here I thought maybe you
could try it and maybe it's a good
alternative maybe you want to try vaping
yes a little pen
dan can you bring in the little pen
let's see if the Joel if we can convert
him into a vapor okay here we go
okay oh my god oh yeah you know it's a
little pen this is our entry-level babe
this if you like it we can get yourself
with something more serious if you want
to go grim yep so go ahead show them how
to use it then let it rip how much you
made I there's this let in a dive like
like all point yeah
there's a slight chance but it'll be
great
so here you yeah push that and then suck
yeah oh yeah that's a fat rip feel great
that's a fat rip it's it's just beep
there's no there's nothing there's
nothing
he's going in for the red no this is a
world record how did you enjoy that
that was interesting it's fun rippings
very clouds and that yeah do you know do
you know there's a competitive vaping
yes I mean I know it's entertaining yeah
well there's different there's different
competitions right like one is how far
you can blow the clouds yeah yeah and
then well they have tricks every trick
volumizing gear that wasn't that was
impressive all right all right enough
enough with the gags it's a flavor is
that I think it's neat unicorn jizz
that's the one that dances so tell me
about your new album it sounds really
interesting and very different than
stuff you've worked on yeah I mean I
haven't been passing an office hey this
is my album and this is a direction I'm
heading in and um [ __ ] all everything
you want because I'm just gonna do [ __ ]
like this from now on it's just more of
a side project really and just so
happened then there was like a large
enough volume of it to constitute
nothing right so all the better which
buys me some time to actually work you
know on another album coming out in the
spring which is going to be more akin to
you know what people usually hear from
me so but this one's cool because it's
actually a collection of like piano
concertos that I've written you know
over the years um and really never had
an outlet form like in terms of like you
know well we can't just like you know
take your weird
just piano only songs and put them on a
CD and sell them who do you think you
are like right Gary Glitter or whatever
all right [ __ ] name but it don't work
astray oh right its lowest rated in this
incident like we I submitted that music
- a friend of mine Gregory wherever it
who is a composer like he composes for
film in massive orchestras and stuff
like that I was like hey can we take
this and then throw 80 player string
sections on it and you have to like
adapt it in such a way that work
musically and all something's like yeah
easy
you know what's already you've given me
more information than I need to do that
so with your melody melodic structure
because it means like trying to take any
modern Indian track he's like the dumb
dog along with one note over and over
again okay let's make an orchestral
version of this okay cue the timpani guy
like you know four four and then maybe
the Contra bass playing the same note
over and over I think my music was
written like more melodic central first
so you know giving that material over to
Greg it was like easy-peasy to
transcribe it and we wrote it you wrote
the melody on piano and then you handed
it off yeah yeah and somewhere it
contracts as well like strobe and stuff
yeah that's so cool that's a really cool
project work so the whole album is
basically orchestrate all it's all
orchestra it's a symphony Wow no like ol
Cynthia which is crazy because you know
I'm reading up on you know I'm a dance
Mozart and all these guys I'm always
written his first symphony we use like
you know 16 and 12 and stuff like that
like well not that no I like the compare
myself that but I mean that would be
something cool to achieve in a lifetime
you know they'd get a body of work out
that's like you know in a traditional
sense an orchestra are you there when
they when they're all together
performing I'm playing the this is my
Ralph
so Joel goes in with people who have
spent tens of thousands of hours playing
and being you know violinists and and
then I walk in with my Moke I'm playing
the mode
so yes I managed to sneak my myself into
the orchestral mix during the
performance it like though being there
with all those people playing your music
um was it cool insane insane audio like
in terms of like the the way you hear it
because you would be surprised how far
off we are you know from the future of
being able to hear something as it's
happening versus how it's recorded into
a DAC and then output because think of
it like this even the most pristine
recording the Dave Brubeck recording of
take five like you know some of the most
legendary recordings playback on two
speakers which are two monophonic sound
sources meaning that there's only like
one speaker with one access one axis
that can move to produce a sound right
and then stereo is just two of them
doing that right but when you think
about it you're not gonna match the
fidelity of say imagine you know sixty
string players are 60 speakers you know
like that don't have phase problems or
correlation problems or all these like
you know kind of weird quasi scientific
terms that you could throw it like
acoustic properties coming for speakers
so sitting on the floor of an orchestra
playing you know your music sounds
insanely different than you know even
with the best mics and the best
recorders recording it and then playing
it back through the speakers it's like a
universal art is there a way for
consumers ever to get an experience like
that without just going to the or no you
absolutely you have to be sitting there
and being in the same room as that you
just shredding away down there so are
you gonna tour with the orchestra
I would love to um I think it'd be cool
like sigh pressures doing long you know
like I said I'd hate for the conception
to go around that like Joel says [ __ ]
dance music and now he's a hans
Zimmerman you know or you're not saying
that no for the record yeah um but I
mean but it's cool first of all it would
be awesome to do but the the to counter
note that the fiscal side of that is
insane Oh mad and a been enjoying
touring with the pillow with
five guys is expensive all right that's
five flights fly five meals five hotel
rooms every five of each times up by a
factor of 80 that's yeah they don't well
what will they do okay
consider a session player like or
someone who performs in an orchestra
whether it's this work show that artists
are they kind of stay where they're at
and they're like robots that's why they
have like the orchestra of this city
mm-hmm yeah absolutely because because
these people are so [ __ ] talented you
could literally put the music in front
of them they've never heard it before
and this is how it went down at the
recording session I'm a second you know
I'm asking the the composer and the
conductor I'm like so how long have you
been practicing
and they're like first right hardened
you know practice yeah I was like just
give me like one take they're like yeah
okay well I have faith and they put the
sheet music in front of them and they
read they're like human computers they
just read the sheet music and play it
exactly as it's notated you know notated
wrong then it's wrong but they didn't
play that [ __ ] wrong you know so I was
like wow that's really insane because I
thought um during the session recordings
that we did at east-west which was like
you know one of the world's best studios
for this kind of thing um I thought well
this is gonna be interesting cuz I've
had keyboardist and you know session
players coming to my studio or other
studios and then we're like okay bar one
a little oh okay well we'll punch you in
from parts 35 and okay boo oh [ __ ] okay
okay boo boo boo boo and I'm like
thinking okay well if we scale that up
two times you know 60 players never get
done it'll never get done
yeah so how does this [ __ ] get done and
then of course their first hand they're
perfect are they're like okay so we
finally get everyone in the room [ __ ]
conductors tap and everyone shut the
[ __ ] up phones off okay here we go
played the whole song flawlessly and
then I was like that's it and they're
like that sound good and I was like that
was like perfect then they were like
yeah well it's what was written on the
thing right thanks Gregory who did that
work I want to know one of you could
ever do something where you like travel
to like municipal orchestras and play
with them so you're
not the first idea that me that would be
so fun
that'd be cool yeah because it's like I
said it's not it's not a matter of
having to move these musicians know what
they're all know what they're doing in
their respective you know locations and
stuff like that like the world is so
interesting man it's really crazy and
and it's funny because my composer
friend is of that world and knows all
this he's done you know Deadpool the
Avengers and all this stuff like all
these big scores and stuff like that and
he's like you know there's just as much
[ __ ] in this as I know that you
haven't danced with like bow ties ins
you know what I mean like well not
really it's a little more laid-back than
that it's not like the white wigs and
those guys sitting around anymore but
besides this is like you know there's
just as much constraint in stylistic
approach that is kind of the norm or
mean stream
orchestral music which is like hard to
fathom if you're not a fan or someone
who's been following you know the latest
greatest symphonies because that's the
thing is everyone can name you know
popular albums at the last five years
right let's say you know Kanye's life a
pop no this and that that you know and
all these other records name name the
last symphony ever written yeah no I
know there's hundreds and thousands you
know which is namely you know it's a
world totally new territory for me so
it's really cool to be able to explore
that you work you were quoted somewhat
recently of saying that EDM is dead or
at least that it's dying
yeah but that was back in 2014 so I'm
wondering what else long yeah so I was
wondering what do you think about the
current state of you know well that's
the thing the current state is the state
it's been in the last five years see I
don't know I think I'm kind of like not
taken out of contact because I I clearly
I mean what I say even if it's like some
weird [ __ ] comment or something like
towards cuz honestly the biggest
question I always get on Twitter what do
you think about dot dot dot like what
the [ __ ] you know okay fine and then I
just say what I'm thinking at that
moment but um here's the thing is when I
started making electronic music it was
literally I started making electronic
music as a joke you know
just kind of a funny thing because it
was like kind of on this weird lull that
it was all starting to kind of sound the
same what what I had done is as I
implemented like at least from my end
you know I'm not saying I'm the only
innovator in you know modern-day man's
dance music there's lots but from my end
of it is I I came from this kind of like
industrial kind of mindset in terms of
music you know what I mean so it's like
I was my melodies were a little more
melancholic like Radiohead a la Nine
Inch Nails kind of thing and I thought
that you know house music which was
actually house music back in the day and
that kind of early stage of techno and
trance early trance like side trance
like we're talking like art of trance
and you know all the Platypus records
kind of trance all that stuff was like
really euphoric sounding in terms of
like you know major key changes like in
scale and stuff like that and it was
just everything was really positive
about it and I go how come no one's done
the the kind of the bummer the
diminished kind of feel you know dance
music just can create like more of an
emotional bummer lo right lo not lull
you know l ull in that kind of music and
I started to do that and then one good
way to achieve that was just you have
really lush sounds that were like you
know kind of long monotonous on like
eight note repeats kind of things and
then that was this track I did called
faxing Berlin kind of thing which was
not like this uplifting kind of MORTAL
KOMBAT yeah you know they write that's
what that's where it was heading him in
my eyes and then that caught on you know
and then then everyone else started kind
of doing it and all that stuff then we
propelled it to this place and then it
just evolved as music does you know it
never comes full circle so it's not
gonna go back to mmm so what you what
you mean it's just it's evolving yeah
it's moved beyond where what yeah it's
just moved beyond I mean it's dead I
mean just that piece of it is that I
know it's done to death that you know so
what do you think about where it is now
I mean what's going on now music as a
whole - like honestly I don't give a
[ __ ] um I haven't really thought about
it much like cuz I'm not if I were smart
and I wanted to make a lot of money I
would absolutely think about where it's
headed and what it's doing and what the
trends are because that's where you go
in you exploit those
there's plenty of Acts doing that right
now you know what I mean where they
gonna say woo this is this is the new
sound this new trap
yeah well I'm like speaking for two
years ago you know what I mean like guys
it's kinda what is trap how to do it is
like hip-hop without [ __ ] you know
rap always over it and other people
analyze these things like you would
running a business analyze trends and
pandered to those kind of trends I've
never really given a [ __ ] about it so
like I don't I don't see that and those
respective kind of things going anywhere
because it's not like of my main focus I
guess I mean they probably think about
just staying relevant whatever that
means
exactly exactly that one of my most
loathed Twitter comments is are you even
relevant right relevant to what finish
the sentence you know what I mean like
just relevant in general relevancy is
like the weirdest word I've ever heard
you know it when it's used in that
context of no context and I mean am i
relevant yeah my cat relies on me defeat
you are very super relevant you know
what I mean like I'm the most relevant
[ __ ] thing in that thing's universe
we don't be relevant finish your thought
finish your thought explain yourself
like I said I really have no qualms with
people making you know like haphazard
guesses as to my state of mind but
please have something to back it up I've
never I've make a point like I try my
best that when I say something even if
it's you know benign or really you know
kind of attacking someone or something
like that I've got like empirical
evidence that founded that statement you
know what I mean I don't just I wouldn't
say I hate you could you look like a guy
hating him drew thank you but I could
tell you a hundred stories about why hey
drew and then that would explain to you
why I don't even like you you that's
great but I do you like you you I
thought I was gonna walk into like a
drag fest I don't know why you expected
that you were expecting all kinds of
crazy [ __ ] hearing you talk about it
yeah man like I'm paranoid as [ __ ] just
sit here alright I don't know
no good I got a boyfriend I think is it
a youtuber thing a youtuber we have a we
have a rap we have a reputation I guess
or some sorts but the podcast is like a
different thing well yeah a youtuber
thing what's a youtuber thing like I
know what a youtuber is yeah yeah just I
don't get any culture at all
I don't understand it Thank You tubers
well the ones with content
the ones with interesting shape people
that put forth an effort into their
production and they you know they clean
it up and they do some really cool stuff
like like say uh would would linus be a
youtuber yeah well it's just really more
even more broth just someone who makes
content on youtube yeah okay okay well
then yeah sure you know like his [ __ ] is
you know he puts research into it he's
yeah he doesn't just [ __ ] throw a
camera up and start [ __ ] calling
people names and acting like a 13 year
old girl like that's one concept that's
just annoying you know what I mean it's
like [ __ ] these kids are gonna be able
to vote in two years you know what I
mean like [ __ ] this I can't watch that
[ __ ] you know like but I'll watch like
you know I really like I don't know if
he's a youtuber though electro boom he's
like an Iranian electrician like oh yeah
super he takes a piece of content makes
it very you know educational I learn
stuff from it and he's he's funny as
hell like he's he's Kitty humour you
know it's not dark that guy is a very
unique yeah you know we need more
lecture isn't like that not like just
some kid [ __ ] talking a mile a minute
in a high-pitched voice about minecraft
yes the mic well the money yes that's
that is YouTube in a nutshell that's why
I don't explore it too much because when
I started to do it I find more of that
than I do
of people who got put together yet it's
hard and just reminded me of a video I
want to show you here we go yeah I just
want to show you this clip and get your
snap judgment on how do I see it I'm
gonna pull only show them Omar bradbury
intro okay I'm
wait this isn't the one no you're gonna
automate doesn't anything like it bro
it's like something you've never you
never seen that's his intro by the way
this is his failure this is what he yeah
this is how he creates all of his new
viewers what what is that what's going
on it's like on slow-mo
on drugs i I don't know man he's a young
guy I think no no no don't get me wrong
if I was like 6 years old I loved it all
right it's great it's hilarious it's
sugar right I like sugar any more sugar
but I'm a [ __ ] adult I'm like I'm a
grown ass my like well yeah I should be
you know what I mean that you have
acquired taste I want to ask you about
basically your experience coming up in
music was unique and and it doesn't
happen that often where you come up
yourself doing your own work you know
really like picking yourself up from the
trenches in a way and building your own
thing that's what you do well yeah in
innocence you know but honestly I think
that the way the universe is so [ __ ]
chaotic and random that a lot of that
had a factor to play with it you got
lucky me you know you know well you know
that had a done at a piece you know what
I mean maybe more so than you know any
talent that I may or may not possess you
know what I mean because I know for a
fact that there are millions of other
artists out there more talented than me
that can't say like well deserve it more
or whatever you know we need their
limelight know it's stuff everyone's
kind of successful in their own ways and
it's not always equated to you know
fiscal game you know or attention in the
media or you know you're super popular
and stuff like that all that [ __ ] like
facilitates itself and it becomes as
force-feedback then because if no one
knew who I was I wouldn't be making
money if I wasn't making money I
wouldn't be able to reinvest into what I
like to do I don't I mean so it's like
this weird luck thing you know it just I
got lucky
in the sense that you know I worked and
increased my chances of that lock
happening yeah you make your luck you
know what I mean so not to say that
you're lucky so therefore you should
just sit on [ __ ] ass with your two
SoundCloud links and wait no you got to
keep going because as you keep going the
that 1% turns into 1.6 you know and at
that point 6 I could just you know throw
you over so what had happened was as
I've been making music for you know
eight years um you know at the time and
you know I come up with this idea and as
luck would have it I met a guy who knew
a guy through real-life connection that
played a record and then he played it
for his friend Pete Tong song played it
and then everyone's like oh who's this
new guy from Canada I'd like to hear
more from him ok well ok I'll work and
then I get a record deal through these
are guys and do more networking and then
that propels it and then all of a sudden
that little tiny 1% Martha turns into
like a [ __ ] 60% you know so and then
it's just literally throw spaghetti at
the [ __ ] wall and work with the ideas
that you know attune to you you know but
yeah I think it's about making your own
luck I don't think it's about oh you
work hard you'll get there you know like
if you can't get past that little
threshold right you know you won't get
anywhere but if that's interesting you
know I was gonna ask what's your advice
for people who are trying to do it you
did but that's exactly it right it's
about making it well yeah that just
working working working but then you
know there there is a networking aspect
and that has changed dramatically in the
last nine years in terms of like say
SoundCloud and stuff like that before
like when I started making electronic
music the computers were just barely
capable of doing it you know what I mean
and so we're talking like trackers
dos-based programs and stuff like that
we're the only kind of computer music
making tools so I was fortunate enough
to be able to you know grow up with that
technology and then the st came out and
i was like at the forefront of that so
now if anything VST comes out now I know
its entire history and how to get it
working the way I want it to or whatever
you know so you're saying back now it's
almost like is it an advantage or
disadvantage that people trying to come
up now have this incredible social
networks yeah well the social networks
are cool you know I guess after a point
but they only work
only do you so many favors your your
best bet is go make real-world
connections because still like all these
major labels or even you know somewhat
labels are like these old people that
just don't give a [ __ ] - listen your
soundcloud you know what I mean so you
want to send a demo - it's a mousetrap
like I mean and I've just probably told
his story to death but like literally
sunny more the Skrillex was maybe about
five years off the back of his band
thing who he's because he's put his time
in with this band from first to last he
did a lot of you know groundwork met a
lot of people not stuff and Tommy Lee at
the time was doing a thing called the
public record which I thought was the
stupidest [ __ ] idea in the world but
he did it anyway it was like I'm gonna
make this record and it's all gonna
we're gonna give out stems to everybody
and everyone's gonna contribute we're
gonna pick stems well funnily enough
Sonny Moore at the time was like one of
the top contributors because he got
involved he got active with the
community you know and he would send in
this [ __ ] in his like weird demos of how
what we should add to this track kind of
thing so we listened to it and then all
of a sudden he became like a mainstay
name down in Tommy studio and we just
like didn't roll down there and say this
you know
yep that's that [ __ ] Skrillex kid you
know and all set and then as it turned
out you know he's like hey we're playing
in LA why don't you come [ __ ] hang
out and use again right you know so he
came and literally in the dressing room
of the Nokia [ __ ] theater Sonny gave
me a key a USB key with the entire his
first album on it right and then I went
home and listened to it and this was
before dubstep was well it dubstep as we
know it in North America with the wire
around transformer [ __ ] was that and
I had heard that for the first time I
know it was like well this is different
like this is exciting this is [ __ ]
crazy like let's put it out and then we
put out his first album and lo and
behold he [ __ ] blew up bigger than me
you know which was [ __ ] awesome you
know isolated that career and I felt
great about it and there's no cos that
he's working with Bieber no [ __ ] it you
know all the power to you you know
better you than me you know trust me I'd
be in jail and you're on billboard
that's good you know assault crazy yeah
you know what I mean so but he made
connections you want to assault Bieber
is there a part of you that wants to
punch Bieber okay let me phrase this why
do you why do you want it why would in a
world you want to punch Bieber oh you
know well maybe not punch hit my shot
let's flip them off flip them on yeah
you know what there was I I do have a
Bieber story yeah I will sure know I
love it um I am I used to be a regular
at this club in Toronto called
Cabana mm-hmm it's just like an outdoor
take club trying to be Vegas and Toronto
kind of thing it's cool you know
laid-back sushis pretty good so me and
my girlfriend we go there and we just
get in Cabana and order [ __ ] food
meet and yell at my friend deejays and
[ __ ] like that that would go and play
there sometimes I would play there and
something so hey everyone
one fine day and an 18 year old beaver
[ __ ] appears ok the [ __ ] place is
out of control it's like it's like
[ __ ] Trump trying to land a 747 at
[ __ ] Chicago O'Hare [ __ ] rush hour
of planes you know we're basically if
the clear everything out make sure he's
got you know line-of-sight to his you
know it was like to his cabana and stuff
like that and I was like oh I really
didn't want to be there you know what I
mean like I was like [ __ ] why am I here
cuz I we gotta go they're gonna have
cameras and someone's gonna do a thing
it was nailing your buddy was one in the
funk yeah and basically I am what I did
as I tweeted as I do
Bieber just showed up party's over right
like this income the [ __ ] paparazzi
in the weirdos yeah so we were just
sitting there and he [ __ ] like just
you know takes off his shirt no [ __ ]
he's like a team dude you're not even
legally allowed to be there for starters
you know but who's gonna say [ __ ] right
so I was just like whatever you know
just maybe this will be okay if I don't
attract any time he [ __ ] looks over
me he's like uh and then everyone's like
going and then whispering at him you
know like hey that's Deb Mouse that's
Deb Mouse and I was like oh [ __ ] you
know because I'm rewinding in my head
thinking like maybe he's read one of
these like earlier tweets so these
things just something like that and what
have you said about him and then he's
like [ __ ] me I don't know he was like
you know so he will tell him to come
here you know I'm like no
you know like I'm not gonna walk over to
your booth and go over there right and
then I and that's over and someone took
a picture me leaning over him and not
say like hey I'm your biggest fan
actually said hey welcome to Canada the
first time I actually said that over is
like [ __ ] security guards someone
took a picture of right at that moment
but just the way that you'll find it
you're gonna people are googling it
right now if you find the pic looks old
up back there yeah it looks like it's
just the way that they caught me in the
photo looks like I'm like reaching thank
you for like or something but I actually
remember saying welcome to Canada the
first time you know I mean like let me
see this photo hey was that [ __ ] up
you got it did they have it you're on it
well that wasn't so so you have a slight
grudge because of the way he tried to
summon your ass over there yeah girl
like I'm sorry dude I'm the one guy that
won't come over here and suck your dick
you know that's part of it that's part
of it yeah yeah yeah that's mostly it he
knows his stance is kind of aggressive
well he was a little he was a little
upset when I said it I just I just mic
drop and then walked out like after that
but they cut me like smiling because it
was probably cuz I was laughing at my
own stupid joke yeah exactly
it looks like a little guarded and you
did a goof on him I don't know it's best
friend it's subjective service like oh
you were just so excited to be on my way
out
so that these no look dude okay okay I
will admit I didn't look that good at 18
yeah he doesn't look good he you
definitely for sure you know it's
thinking this I wouldn't be taking my
shirt off no no people pay me to leave
it on when I had cool tats though before
he got is is this the only time you guys
have have crossed paths that's it oh no
no oh oh [ __ ]
Dean do we still have that I don't know
if we have a picture of it but [ __ ]
nah he threatened to kill me what yeah
yeah yeah
battle in Australia in Australia Jared
drew that's why I remember we
you look like Drew Ressler drew Ressler
was a old photographer used to take my
picture Brooks right right and you
really look like rooks it's kind of
scary that's why it's almost morning man
so that was yeah so he's my photographer
in Australia he was also shooting Bieber
right so but this was way before this
even and then Bieber he wrote on his
like a picture of himself hi Deb Mouse I
will kill you I'm dead [ __ ] serious I
gave it to rooks and then say give that
to deadmau5 right and then so rooks came
to me with this [ __ ] photos says here
you just Bieber want me to give you this
I was literally a picture of like 15
year old him on an acoustic guitar so I
will kill you say that why when you
frame that put that up with your taxes
we I think we literally just left it in
the dressing room yeah threat from
Justin Bieber was that what was that
after your person encounter he was in no
it was before so that's how we broke the
ice with you I apparently no no no the
first time the first time you broke ice
with me was me having to listen to him
talk to his whole crew in the room next
door paper-thin walls at the Grammys or
which which is the thing in the States
the Grammys yeah yeah he was at the
Grammys he was in the room next to me
and then we could hear the conversations
going on room we were like what what was
he saying
hi I'd rather not enough to say what the
[ __ ] enough to say what yeah okay I'm
like who's in there and then okay you
know and then we were right ooh that's
kind of weird and then and then maybe a
few months later we ended up in
Australia basically we were both touring
at the same time and then that's when we
got that letter there's got to be a
picture that's now I know how to create
my friends and love yeah it's kind of
I've never really spoken award we've
never had a dialogue oh man I feel like
I got to get you guys in a room would
you do that no you don't know if you're
listening Justin get this man another
picture it says I will kill you I've
nothing
I dare I from all
learned about you know your prowess and
musical talents I am just not interested
in nothing I could gain hmm I feel bad
for the guy in a way I mean I think he's
matured a lot first of all basically I
upgraded from passing and [ __ ] bucket
right backstage I mean yeah you've been
doing and that's doing quite well
that's how age works too apparently
you're supposed to mature as you get
older but I didn't know you can do that
I'd be doing that I was like you can get
away without [ __ ] the guy is like so
like he can't leave his house without
being looked like brutally harassed okay
that I can decide but because like I get
mildly harassed
I was a little mildly harassed outside
of your place were you really no not not
mildly he's just like did he give me a
thumbs up in wait to kill you anything
but you know being being [ __ ] you
know escorted around everywhere by a
bunch of rings a little attention [ __ ]
that all right I like I like where I'm
at I think I'm in my perfect room you
know I was like okay a couple weirdos
here and there but ya know it's not like
you can go outside and do all right
let's take it to a quick quick
commercial break guys we will be right
back with Joel Zimmerman stay tuned
we'll be right back what are you doing
Ethan hmm I'm eating honey which by the
way is the name of our sponsor today and
I would never turn down free honey but
what's one thing I definitely would
never turn down even more than that free
money honey that's what that's what
honey is all about listen to this if you
shop online without the best coupons
you're already paying too much
fortunately there's a free browser
extension called honey that
automatically finds the best coupons on
the web so you always get the best price
let me preface this by saying this I
installed this browser you you install
it from the Google Play Store or
whatever whatever you're using it
installs immediately into seconds and
what it does is it scours the web for
every coupon ever created for whatever
your
shopping for and it plugs it in it
searches and it plugs it in so I'm on
New Balance like a grandpa looking for
some new shoes because I'm looking at
his yeah looking for some extra - ooh as
I go in the search bar type dad got a
couple that I like I go look at this I
saved 53 bucks this I would have paid
full price and you just check out you
don't need to do anything it just tells
you yeah when you're checking out it's
just like hey there's coupons available
you click apply it just pops up and then
it's like not only do you have dad shoes
now but your dad would be proud about
you that bad coupon - dude what the hell
and then and then the other day we were
we mean ela just moved and we were
buying some new furniture I swear to God
I didn't save it because I was so
shocked but I swear we saved a thousand
freaking dollars it may sound like we're
making it up but seriously it's not a
joke it's blowing my mind this stuff and
it's free to use all you have to do is
go and saw it boom at two clicks honey
to any add it to any for browsers for
free and shop like you normally do honey
scans and testimonies of coupons in the
background I check out they
automatically apply the best one over
seven million people use honey every day
and together they've saved millions of
bucks honey's got your back you'll never
pay overpay for anything ever again so
there's no reason there's really no
reason not to add honey to your browser
right now it's free it takes seconds to
install and it's gonna save you tons of
money add honey to your browser for free
right now go to join honeycomb slash h3
that's join honeycomb / h3 that way they
know who sent them just give it a shot
if you don't like it I don't know why
you won't you can just uninstall it it's
literally the greatest freaking
extension ever thank you so much Donnie
for sponsoring us and next up we've got
Squarespace if you need a domain a
website an online store a blog a beauty
blog a makeup my wicked website just
wanna make a cool website to show you
art yeah Squarespace has got you covered
here's what's so great about Squarespace
they've got beautiful templates they
give you all the tools that you need to
make an incredible beautiful elegant or
nutty whatever you want to do it
yourself you don't have to be a
programmer right you don't to be a NASA
scientist you know sometimes it feels
like that when you're trying to make a
website here they've got everything you
need to make a beautiful elegant website
for whatever you need from commercial to
personal yadda so that's about it
they've got an all-in-one platform
there's nothing to install or patch it's
ready to go when you get it they've got
incredible analytics that helps you gain
insight into how your your customers are
behaving on your website and they make
it easy to learn by providing webinars
workshops and 24/7 customer support they
want you to succeed because when you
succeed they succeed and that is a
beautiful world that I can get behind
Squarespace makes it simple to set up
and transfer your domains so if you want
to create a website for any any
possibility say you're like my friend
Sean he makes you harps musical
instrument why it's called a Jew harp
that's not weird of me to say but it
trips me up every time I say it he may
you maybe want a website to sell your
jobs maybe yours maybe you whatever
you're doing okay maybe you want to
start a clothing line yeah you can do
there Squarespace my dudes here's the
deal destiny is calling you have no
excuse so going on over - dang
squarespace.com slash h3 you get a free
trial and 10% off you're free free
purchase searches so go head on over to
squarespace.com slash h3 and fulfill
your destiny to make a badass website
it's more than that though your
interests your dreams everything it's
tied up at squarespace.com so ch3 thank
you everybody
let's get right back into it thank you
to our sponsors please support them okay
see you guys cut me off then
so you're how do you like being in LA
you're here to promote the new album
well now I'm here to to perform this
shows oh the oh you're doing yeah yeah
we're doing two shows at The Wiltern
okay cool yeah so we're doing like the
orchestra at The Wiltern ah yeah further
ado I'll bow yeah you are putting on
with the orchestra yeah that's exciting
this is like some marketing tactic no
you say you are planning on performing
with the orchestra oh oh no no no
everyone's been asking oh sorry I
misunderstood everyone's been asking me
are you gonna tour it no we're doing two
performances you got it yeah but like as
far as after that I don't know that I've
got a gun yeah okay my bad is that like
do they play orchestras at that theater
usually is it like set up acoustically I
think so yeah that's awesome yeah it's
exciting The Wiltern it's like that
little old theater downtown kind of name
right it's set up for Orchestra for sure
that's awesome we just had to scale it
back by like 20 players because of just
the real estate cuz 80 players just a
lot of space mm-hmm that's like
Hollywood Bowl space and we're not quite
there yet so so do you like it used to
live in LA right I did for a year as you
told me backstage but you don't like it
here um not that I don't like it like I
don't like the people I don't like the
weather well I don't like the sunshine I
don't like that no rain everybody that a
lot of people don't like it um no I mean
like I I didn't like it in sense that
like I I spend more time with my lawyer
and my manager my agent than I did
doing things I enjoy I am working yeah
yeah exactly
boy now you live you have this
incredible house which I mean I think
most people were fans I've seen it
because you you're there all the time
you stream from home oh yeah the house
is incredible you built did you build
that yourself we bought it like kinda
sorta finished and the guy kind of ran
out of stuff and then we made I'm gonna
offer he couldn't refuse photograph of
you saying oh no no we put a [ __ ]
decapitated horse head no chorus of
course the classic yeah but you're out
in rural out and like how rural is it um
not so rural that you know we have to
drive an hour and a half you know down
country roads like we're a 20-minute
drive to the airport and a 40 minute
drive to down
that's so bad fun so I'm wondering
because you're you are very public about
like the house and you're always there
and people I guess people probably know
where it is do you have a lot of weirdos
showing up there all right well yeah
sure
you know like but just mostly benign
nothing you know dry by yelling I mean
it's it's it's gated in the sense that
not like it's you can't just roll you
can't just come into the front door and
knock on the [ __ ] right it's just you
know the first thing we had to do no
brainer but I mean people are generally
pretty respectful I mean you know like I
don't mind you know people driving by
slowing down and maybe even stopping
inside the road take a look that's fine
you know it's we've only ever had you
know to in the last like three years of
people that have like you know hopped
over the fence and you know that's got
in my [ __ ] well it's a little freaky you
know and in the sense that for for
instance actually a video was put up
recently of a guy who flew a drone over
my house and I saw an aerial picture of
your house I hope oh it was probably me
yeah it was probably me oh yeah yeah I
do it all time and then I public eight
that post so with that well what did
what he what he was doing is he was
parked on the street which isn't my
property it's a [ __ ] public road and
he was flying his drone over like we
have a 50-acre farm lot that's like on
the other side of our property yeah I
got like horses and goats out slow Wow
the goat yeah go goats
yeah the gut with the goat um anyway he
was he was he was parked on the street
and he was flying a drone like you know
over the house over the thing and
basically we were and we were sitting
down in the living room and like is
there is that a drone and we were like
[ __ ] and then we saw the drone in the
night just kind of followed it line of
sight cuz it's gonna land it if he wants
it back
right so and then he takes it and he's
at some truck and I went up to the truck
I'm like what the [ __ ] are you doing
dude you know what
yo he's just giving me this like [ __ ]
he's dropping there he's dropping the
[ __ ] all these aviation laws on me and
I'm like okay but I don't want a
Hawaiian camera over my house you know
and turned into a thing and I'm a
prezzie wasn't like excited to see you
he's just defensive immediately
yeah kinda and he's like well you know
first he started saying well my I was
testing my drone broke I'm like dude I
don't want to hear it just like you know
there's a million [ __ ] we are
literally on three hundred of four
thousand acres of open field where you
could fly drones and and if you weren't
such a dick about it and flying it over
my house you know like you could I just
hit me up somehow if you're especially a
member of our community and you know you
know I love this hobby come over we'll
fly drones of get right if I can smash
me into each other and have a laugh
right drink some beer but like if you're
gonna you know get it right up in my
face about you flying a drone over me
and don't expect me to be upset well I'm
not upset because of aviation laws and
harassment and weird [ __ ] I'm upset
because like [ __ ] I don't know what your
intentions are and it's not my job to
sit here and wonder what they are yeah
so like I I and then I'm thinking like
you know it would be a really great idea
if you want to break into like you know
a nice house out on a real property
flying around the [ __ ] place scouted
out so with their points of entry is you
know what I mean how do I know you're
not doing that if I don't know what I
mean so like that's why I'm freaking out
yes now he's not like oh I understand
you oh [ __ ] you're who I have the right
and then he lets me I'm like holy [ __ ]
like one of these guys that like walks
around with like a ar-15 he's yeah I see
try right cuz he can't yeah cuz he can't
its freedom you heard about these guys
these I don't know yeah the open carry
yeah I would just to be provocative bine
yeah I I think if no one gets provoked
they'd stop doing it you know what I
mean I'm not I'm not like I said I'm not
about saying oh that's stupid we
shouldn't let anyone walk around with an
air how about this everyone walking
around with an air we just don't don't
even don't give him the mass potential
unless they're pointing it at you well
the police show up like dude you're
walking around a shopping mall that's
their response weapon can I ask you some
questions how [ __ ] dare you use your
top that well okay I mean you know yeah
it happens it's we live in strange times
and some are getting crazy with drones
because I went when we bought one we
wanted to just try it for the first time
and we tried it in our neighborhood and
I kind of got calls no I just saw how
creepy you can because you can just fly
it over people as how sleepy fastened
yeah yeah um and and I always thought
like one-one like simple kind of like
thing maybe an administration could do
is maybe just like RFID them so
basically by a drone that's bound to
your you know think they've talked about
doing that why not you know what I mean
like it's nothing stupid hide you know
what I mean but then again that goes
against the second amendment which is
like well I shouldn't be impeded on any
of my freedoms anyway so but hey it's
not like a we're not living in a lawless
country you know exactly so what do you
as a drone fanatic do you see some kind
of dystopian like threat from these
flying drones like they're getting
smaller and quieter it could be one
right outside your dark window and you
wouldn't even know it what am i if I had
a weird thing going on inside my house
that I should be worried about someone
capturing on film you know what I mean
but I'd also like to see my wiener yeah
well like I would love to see what media
outlet would capture someone's a legal
footage and then put it out there out
there and not get sued for six that's
two million yeah so guys if you art
there with drums you know drone is he
[ __ ] Hogan's dick you know that did
not work out well for the man how great
was that he's talking about Gawker who
published nudes illegal Newt it's so
insane yeah like that's crazy what they
would pick up you know but then you
would think that you know there's some
sanity in that market where it's like
someone comes out use like like I said
if I flew a drone over [ __ ] I don't
know
Charlie's thorns house and then caught
her naked in the [ __ ] thing right now
oh now I've got this on my memory card
on my drone woohoo I got away with it
well that is worthless dude cuz you I
cannot go buck to anyone and do that
you're just [ __ ] either way but
someone will pick it up you know yes
somebody will um what other tech are you
are you interested in the people maybe
you are a tech guy your house yeah yeah
yeah easiest technology I'm all over the
board
I love 3d imaging tacking the software
modeling software like 3d graphics I
love that stuff which kind of then
throws you into GPU technology which is
like I'm a huge fan of that
um you know like I gotta have the latest
and greatest should be you and that
either you know helps out my 3d
rendering stuff or the video gaming
yeah gaming yeah this is like I'd love
to be able to look at y'all's neon
without what do you think about all like
all the graphics cards are being sold
out because of the Bitcoin III think
that'll fizzle out as a Bitcoin we have
friends who are like heavily invested
yang I'm not first I'm not invest at all
I'm just I love this the gist of it yeah
yeah yeah yeah that's great the main the
mania is just it's so weird I I just
might my only think the big big thing
that why I never and I'm pretty savvy
investor I have many investments like
you know with companies and stocks and
all this stuff but the one thing I will
not get buying Crypt occurs is for one
solid reason there's no commodity it
doesn't it's not it's just yeah exactly
if there was a commodity I would
understand but and then people try to
explain it to you and then that
conversation just gets so convoluted
with weird [ __ ] that makes my skeptical
that if there's anything there all
because well there's not every time
something explains it like oh no I know
that there's no value backing it up but
this is what and I'm like that's that it
still doesn't make sense you shouldn't
be paid to move electrons around it
doesn't make sense though and it's weird
how like they're just like I heard a
statistic that like the amount of energy
used to farm bitcoins is now worth it's
equivalent to like a whole country's
power consumption
it's like 2% of the world's power
consumption like we're just we're like I
don't know but they're what they're just
like wiping energy off the and it
definitely feels weird that that's even
affected GPU sales markets you know I
mean so if you don't know like they're
the GPU is the most important thing in
mining the coins and so people are
buying so many that also there's they're
sold out because the demand it's
economics 101 it's it's but it's not
it's not the hugest hit you know for
GPUs and stuff like that you know like
there are billions of applications or
GPUs other than mining of course but
maybe it's just Nvidia maybe they
invented bitcoins just to sell more GPUs
the giant conspiracy I'm pretty sure
they have destroy the [ __ ] out of any
NVIDIA GPUs
I guess they need them well any anyone
who makes a GPU yeah
military doesn't have a [ __ ] GPU
Department they buy that [ __ ] probably
em from somewhere else and all that
technology was outsourced I'm not saying
I'm not throwing anyone out of there
it's like GE you know what I mean ge
makes [ __ ] you know guidance systems
for nuclear warheads why wouldn't [ __ ]
Nvidia supply with a right [ __ ] guide
that thing because they have the best
technology for it right you know why
would the government go and spend you
know forty billion dollars like in their
own branch of GPU it doesn't make any
sense
can somebody bring me in a glass of
water I've asked in my water I took a
cue from Joel and I regret it I asked in
all how many things are you smoker I
smoke I like being around people who
smoke cuz it lets me smoke but many
times I've done that cocaine thing so
close cuz you yeah it happened to me
once my mistake brutal never again don't
worry I've actually that's happened to
me on stream once I find it so
interesting that you're a streamer but
not only just a streamer you've been
doing it from before twitch you were
like one of their earliest I mean yeah
yeah I suppose would like um I think it
was when I think one of the first guys
to kind of take on sure it was you
stream Oh you stream was one of the
first ones one of them yeah just in TV
yeah yeah you stream was before that
okay Justin was actually founded from
some people didn't became twitch right
yeah some of them right I think so
what was it about - about streaming
early on when four was popular that it
was well it wasn't it wasn't the concept
of streaming it was like well [ __ ]
streaming I just mean like it would be
really cool that you know cuz the nature
of electronic music is all heavily
produced right mm-hmm
right it's not recorded live off the
floor by a bunch of talented musicians
it's like just adjusted whittling away
doing multiple paths company and and
then it always just came out like okay
here's DJ so-and-so with his new album
right and 30 tracks really you know I
always thought well wouldn't it be
really cool if everyone knew you know
not that like I have to expose anything
but I just mean it's really be cooler to
like open up the hood on it and show
people the process of it you know either
inspire encourage other people to do it
because it's like well maybe that
doesn't look so hard or that's
interesting way of doing things kinda
think you know just lifting hood on it
um so that was something I was always
about because like not not because
someone said oh you've got ghost
producers making your albums and I was
like haha no I don't hear I'm going to
stream myself making music twenty
forever and now you know it's all me now
it's kind of more you know just you know
lifting a veil on something that's just
been heavily veiled for the longest time
and like you said when you stream came
out and stuff like that new electronic
artist was you know showcasing or
live-streaming their production process
right I think I was probably among the
first people more guarded about that
well absolutely because a lot of it is
mystifies looking at any album produced
by you know your favorite artists name
is probably the eighth one down the list
yeah you know what I mean like cuz if
you even are hiring ghost producers if
you're not crediting them unless you
were on some crazy NDA
you know what I mean then you gotta give
them credit you know and so you're gonna
see produced executive producer and then
a list of names and all that stuff
and that's just something how I've also
weighed artists in terms of artistic
merit you know it's like you know a lot
of albums come out by you know let's
just say more mainstream producers and
stuff like that and you're just like
holy [ __ ] this credit listing is longer
than my dick you know and you're right
what you know this makes no sense you
know like interest I I take a certain
amount of you know pride and soul you
know that at the end of the day so
sluice written recorded jolzi yeah and
it's your project it's authentic ly yeah
yeah yeah so I mean is there ever a
reason for somebody to have ten
producers dole is just to make the work
easier or pick up talents where you
didn't
or you know engineering standpoint you
know because well and not to not to say
that that's terrible and they all suck
if you have more than one producer dude
there are musicians who are great at
writing music but are terrible engineers
and producers there are great engineers
and producers who can't write a [ __ ]
melodies save their lives
you know what I mean so those people
have to come together at some point you
know what I mean so it's not it's not
evil that you know multiple people work
on a project it's just do you think that
people or artists who utilize I know you
say that you have to list them as
credits generally speaking but our
artists not forth coming enough with how
much they actually put into that I don't
know like I don't have enough free time
to go in and [ __ ] but start asking
questions wrong friends and about this
and who's really doing all this himself
kind of thing it's like I don't give a
[ __ ] it's like I've got Mouse problems
worry about not [ __ ] BT problems you
know right you know it's not that big of
a deal like because again it's the end
product that's gonna you know push the
thing forward not so much as it was
involved in all that stuff but for me
and my show in my universe and this is
how I see it I don't I don't see myself
as part of some you know group of you
know people say colleagues or you know
all your EDM counterparts and I should
call that man like like I like just this
and controlling this and being my own
artist and doing my own things on my own
time and through my own volition as
opposed to working as a team and collab
bro collabs like why is collaborating so
[ __ ] huge with mainstream music I
don't understand it you know like were
they more get you more get you more
sales exposure right but it doesn't it
doesn't
attribute anything to it other than that
you know it doesn't make the product
better it doesn't make it sometimes it
makes it a nation yeah that's what I
mean I'm like fulfill the really the
exams are the great music from back in
the you know the 60s 70s rock bands and
all [ __ ] it's like Edgar Winter did not
collaborate with Led Zeppelin to do this
you they all had their own vehicles
that's what it's about you know like
it's like [ __ ] buying a McLaren you
know and then having a [ __ ] ride
share it with 30 [ __ ] you know I
mean and you get it back and there's a
[ __ ] stain on the seat you know like
[ __ ] it's just not enjoyable you know
you're just a solo dude yeah
and that applies to a lot of [ __ ] you
know not just my music like I like
living alone
you know I was like oh this must be so
lonely in that epic land streaming room
I'm like no well maybe for you that
needs [ __ ] 30 people sucking your
dick every 20 [ __ ] seconds or giving
you praise or [ __ ] hanging out and
being bros and I'll show I don't mean
that you know what I mean I adore it
I want to ask you about some context on
this this [ __ ] I this is this is an
ancient one oh that was funny I love ya
good
what is this photo that is a photo of me
that Grammys and that they wouldn't let
me wear it when I was performing I they
made they made me take it oh yeah
because it's like a mic illegal edition
I guess but that was actually Skrillex
for number like that was legit his
number I had that made like and I didn't
tell a soul that I was doing this like
management [ __ ] Dean out there and
none of them my lawyer would never have
let me do it right literally hot-swap
that last [ __ ] second and then went
on the red carpet but that was a Sony's
I was just a joke you know been skating
like oh yeah it was hilarious I thought
was funny because this poor kid like
wins like a million Grammys that day it
is phony can he's probably wondering
what [ __ ] is going on of course he
didn't find out till like way later that
night that like I basically gave his
number out there was a stone the Gryphon
how did he react did you talk to him
about it yeah yeah he was like you're an
[ __ ]
you know like bro [ __ ] you know I like
[ __ ] nothing subdued in high school
you know I mean yeah it was just one of
those that's just banter it's it wasn't
it wasn't it it wasn't an attack it
wasn't whatever it was just some fun it
was always and I seen some other people
start to do it after another lame come
on I didn't die I agree in that kid yeah
what we saying it happened to us once
when our phones were being put public
and so what did about it
well that wasn't that wasn't that was so
a hack Turkey mobile account and tweeted
our number but I can only imagine what
his phone was like as hours
couldn't even unlock it or anything
because it was just non-stop incoming
calls and you just I couldn't do
anything it was just like that yeah that
was your life yeah yeah he got over it
I'm emotionally scarred for the rest of
his life no I think could be fun
no people seem to think like I just
literally hate everyone but half these
guys I see like every other month you
know out in LA at some function or
another and it's like it's like it's
like you know the cartoon with the
coyote and Ralph Ralph no she can
[ __ ] hit the clock and then and then
get on the big screen and just start
[ __ ] eating each other but the beef
is more playful yeah yeah it's it all is
like I mean I probably knocked Swedish
House Mafia last night and that means
like I know Steve Angello as well as you
want that like we're bros and i don't
call them every [ __ ] day but we share
the same space sometimes you know and
then we see each other we don't like
[ __ ] watch each other shoulder bump
you know Haman alright well so recently
some [ __ ] went down with this guy DJ
carnage was that a friendly part that
was that was some that was next level I
didn't really understand what happened
it could have been right I would have
liked it to have been but the guy got a
little well I I don't know okay this is
how stupid it must have been I don't
remember the the starting point of this
exchange probably just this bananas me
saying that the next guy is like like I
said make fun of Swedish House Mafia for
half a minute
see him at the next show oh hey man yeah
good one got me goddamn bro you know
whatever you know and then have a beer
[ __ ] shrug it off it was probably
something like that but this guy is like
just this drama queen so he propels it
but not like the Who am I thinking of
the actor man on the moon kind of propel
it often you know what I mean like he's
not next oddly he's like actually taking
this [ __ ] seriously and then it's just
like okay like I'm gonna just stop
[ __ ] with this idiot you know and
then oh I know exactly what it was so I
was approached by razor to do a piece on
you know music and and their products
and stuff like that for because you know
like I'm not gonna be sponsored by neath
and be like hey everybody this is me and
my
Neve console only $500,000 for this
console and you too can make your own
electronic music well I think that the
thing with Razer came about and I was
happy to do it not because of the
fidelity because of the accessibility is
a very cheap product affordable if you
want to just start to learn and kind of
how music is and if it's not for you you
didn't [ __ ] blow five grand on a
laptop and all [ __ ] and right you know
so it was I thought oh this is an
interesting brand yeah I'd love to get
on board with that so no and then they
said part of our kind of agreement on
the side is for lack of details was well
just provide me with ELISA other artists
who are like involved and then they're
like oh this guy this guy this guy knows
I go great and then and then they put
carnage in there and I was like whoo I'm
like I'm not sure that's a great idea
cuz this guy's got a mouth and and I
don't think he's quite technically you
know with it to be able to explain and
lo and behold they went and did it
anyway and didn't tell me and then this
video comes up of the razor add right
and it was like kind of along with ours
and he said things like I don't know
what this knob does but it just makes it
louder like way very more louder it was
memed you know it was like and everyone
was just like you know first of all
you're pirating this software you know
and he's been publicly you know called
out by the software companies that have
been pirated yeah he's like he's like
you know oh he tweets everyone pirate
silence like not like anyone's gonna
make an issue about it and then
literally Leonard Digital quoted his
tweet and said we would love to make an
issue out of this you know and then
basically that got shut down real quick
right and and so because of that tweet
exchange I called you know one of the
higher-ups at Razer and I said you need
to pull this guy off right now so they
buried it they deleted the video took
them right off the campaign said no
we're not having it and then I basically
said told you you know and then they're
like okay okay so obviously that gets
back that carnage yeah and he's like
[ __ ] that Mouse okay I'm like dude you
did it to yourself you know like you
very way way way more did that to
yourself so that I think that's what
really ignited the flame and M you know
and then I was just like and then what
had happened most recently like maybe
three four months ago I don't know it
was cold it was somewhere in the winter
and he he was playing a same festival
that I was playing and then another act
in between us and then I was playing and
then I remember reviewing the billing
before we go to this festival and then I
said to the kind of management and I
said guys can we just keep this guy away
from me because I just I just don't want
any exchange at all I don't even want to
say hi I don't know just now I just want
anything to do with them so like if we
can space this out and they said okay
it'll space it out so we're gonna put a
40-minute changeover in between him and
you because they got a wheel a [ __ ]
13-ton cube up there so there's gonna be
some time you know in between him
finishing him mean going on so and then
I think it was just you know I'm
headlining the show or whatever and he
was like you know not headlining so he's
like being carnage so he's doing his
thing and I'm in the dressing room NORs
near the [ __ ] stage it's literally a
cart ride to it and when he was done he
sat on the side of the stage and waited
the whole time like after he was done
just waiting just waiting for me to come
on cuz he knows I gotta go there right I
gotta go Lloyd exactly so there was like
obviously some like words were exchanged
with the promo room like guys we told
you a million [ __ ] times and that's
why you know but anyway what ended up
happening was is of course I'm going on
stage and I'm thinking maybe he's gone
but knowing him he's probably just
[ __ ] sitting right there so so me and
security are literally be lining the
stage and that's what I do you know like
I respect other artists even if I
[ __ ] hate them that your time slot
your time slot so you go in you do your
[ __ ] thing and you leave that's the
off no that's not Twitter that's not
your harassment playground you just
[ __ ] do your [ __ ] and get out that's
your job and I take my job [ __ ]
seriously oddly enough so I'm I'm
walking to the stage and he's [ __ ] I
just caught him in the corner of my eye
and then started to do out of my way
like to get way back in the safe and he
just becomes so like getting in my face
it's like what's up do the duel and then
my security guy doing his [ __ ] job
did one of these like yeah dude you are
getting right in his face and then all
of a sudden two others
it turned into a thing and I just I
avoided it like I got it like you got a
shove on me and I'm like all right okay
you know he called it yeah yeah so I I
just went and sat at the bottom of my
cube where I've got a big [ __ ]
dude that's his job and you're why this
guy needs a job you know what I mean so
yeah so I'll just sit here and I sat on
the phone and I'm like this is gonna
suck because there's another guy with
the camera right like he has a guy we
don't do this but like some musicians or
whatever DJ's have a guy that follows
them around with a camera just document
everywhere so yeah yeah this guy's got
this camera running right the garnish
yeah so I'm thinking well this is not
good for him because literally your
camera guy is just filming you coming up
to me [ __ ] pushing me and screaming
at top your lungs are gonna [ __ ] kill
me and right I'm like it's this [ __ ]
guy's problem you know I'm like so I was
I was upset so but I mean I'm not gonna
go and [ __ ] challenge a 400-pound
[ __ ] Pillsbury [ __ ] DJ boy you
know like over [ __ ] some [ __ ] you
know like I don't care I'm there to do a
job
and I'm not gonna let that ruin my time
up there that you know I have a you know
my fans that came to see me or his fans
that were left over that have to see me
you don't like whatever you know I was
like yeah [ __ ] okay out of mine I would
say and then you know my production
manager comes is like you do you know
like that's like straight-up assault and
you know you could and I'm like well
fine do what you got to do but just get
them just have them removed you know
like so I don't have to see him when I'm
done you know what I mean because I just
want to go up there do my [ __ ] and get
the [ __ ] out and go to the next one you
know and and then that's what happened
you know and then security said you know
you know your your show ended an hour
ago you need to leave that's part of the
deal you know so go and he made a big I
can fit about it and that's like every
opportunity that he gets it's like and I
ignore it which is fine you know this is
a smartest [ __ ] thing I could do so
often immediately he immediately goes to
Twitter but tells a whole story I'm like
to curl up yeah that's it and I don't
talk about it I don't care about it I'm
not gonna feed them a ously am now but
let this be the end of it
just you know yeah that's what it is so
it's just there are people like that and
everyone's lives you know someone's just
happen to get you together you're smart
of the game right that they play about
like yeah you know just leave it ignore
it and hopefully it doesn't escalate you
know maybe he gets his [ __ ] problem
sorted out on his end or whatever but
that's not my problem yeah does it get
to you when you have to perform after an
annoying thing happens yeah a little bit
but I don't want I mean this is not like
braggadocious but like I've been
performing and doing my thing
I could literally play like you know ten
minutes after my friend kills himself
you know and I did so like it was weird
you know like like I can I can perform
under any circumstance which I'll just
turn it on turn it off and then throw
the blinders up do your [ __ ] thing
and then off the stage deal with your
[ __ ] that's dark that was it I'm sorry I
did literally I speak my mind and
literally that popped up I was thinking
well what was the worst-case scenario I
had to play no my friend Stephen crutch
key rest in peace man damn well oh he's
out I find myself very it's icy out yeah
you've got pets and antics and they
taste a tail so if they stop you know
emotionally fulfilling you then you eat
them yeah yeah yeah when they when they
stop becoming fun yeah baby goats oh
look at them they're like little spring
so now they're like no you just sit
there and eat Hey I don't fun anymore
no I lied now our pets our pets and our
food is our food sometimes both I eat my
chickens eggs that's fair that's fair
that's good no that's very they do it
anyway the egg yeah yeah yeah they just
[ __ ] out eggs yep no they I have eggs
and toast every morning from our three
chickens I've know that people have
their own chickens
does it taste different is it somehow
different or is it the same [ __ ]
the eggs oh no they these are monster
eggs really yeah I think they're
[ __ ] like their egg vents or
whatever they are no they're they're
like crazy they're really good like
maybe two eggs will [ __ ] do it for me
really yeah yeah no they're huge they're
big brown one so I was like well I'm not
I don't know how maybe we got lucky and
we got soup got chicken we like super we
pamper them they're like Kelly's like
babies you know like she called wood
they grew up in our house right like so
you imagine this house and you know all
the pictures the inside we literally had
chickens [ __ ] and running around in
the house it was hilarious until they
started [ __ ] everywhere I'm like
okay let's go you run as as everything
you do you're very much on your own in
terms of running your own social media
instagram twitter twitter you have all
kinds of exposure to like fans opinions
about you how do you feel being exposed
like to all these chatter and all these
people talking especially their opinion
where most people as popular as you
don't have they don't know they've got a
wall yeah they're right or something I
know what I mean I don't know I get to
do it does but that's the price you paid
for being you know like [ __ ] super
crazy vocal on things or whatever you
know I mean it's like I've touched
everything from [ __ ] politics to
[ __ ] to stock the [ __ ] personal
opinions and all [ __ ] and yeah it's just
that's that's me being antisocial being
social you know putting in there there's
my social activity for the day I'm gonna
go back to playing pop G hours on it I
think I'm an antisocial person you know
like I don't enjoy being around crowds
of people or even my closest friends
know that you know I can only see them
like four hangs maybe half an hour a
week at some restaurant or something and
then that's it you know so I've
developed a really good shell in terms
of being to be able to deal with
stupidity idiots you know and and all
that kind of backlash that you get when
you [ __ ] try to be social in it
my attempts of being social might come
off as you know [ __ ] snarky or
facetious or attacking you know but
that's just me being me you know and
I've and I've just been doing it so long
that I think that people who have been
following me or know of me or whatever
just say oh that's just they now you
know social media as a while ago you had
erased Facebook and Twitter right for
like a minute for like like a minute I
don't know what you do you know what it
was or I can't remember something about
you you were tired of all the [ __ ]
of annoying people I think maybe yeah
you know maybe some weird thing it was a
while ago it was it was probably a swing
you know everyone has these [ __ ] up
swings you know like you know that's
just part of being you know
manic-depressive I guess which I guess
self-diagnosing myself I could be a
little more of that direction
you know but like okay I'm like this is
Groundhog Day you know like I've been
upping it down and up and down which is
kind of yeah I think we're leaving for a
lot of my core fans because they oh wow
yeah [ __ ] days - yeah yeah well yeah
there's a very big misconception about
you know what wealthy people are like or
you know successful people are like
inside even people think you're happy
all the time I think it's evident it's a
really it's a really interesting thing
because like I said when I was before I
was dead mouse or anything like that you
know I would think that you know you
know even just coming across say Tommy
Lee's radar for the first time before I
was [ __ ] anybody you know I'm getting
an email wow this guy must be like
[ __ ] live in life being like crazy
happy in Russia as you get I got to know
him over the [ __ ] years I'm like wow
this guy has some [ __ ] dark days and
this guy's yeah you know as is fun too
but like you know having in this state
and having money is its holy has nothing
to be you find a new plateau there and
then it becomes normal it's not like
you're getting rich every day where it's
like that excitement of the plateau yeah
yeah and then you live your life so you
think of it like the well now like
my level I have to think now like whoa
who's happier me or Jeff Bezos right
you know that guy's probably just as
maybe miserable as the next guy
surely you know like what does that when
someone like yeah but yeah I'll say it
comes with so much I'm like you know
it's wait [ __ ]
yeah it's waiting yeah it's not just
like ooh money and less money let's just
go spend it all and have no Laurie it
let's go will never happen yeah anyone
in the world is Jeff based this guy be
miserable I'll tell you what he's
hurting a little bit
why cuz Amazon stocks now yeah was
because what did Trump say he wonder
what happen you want it investigated
like adding tax law I think he's just
bought her cuz he owns the one no he's
just but I think Trump is just like a
perpetual a little just just this
[ __ ] jealous little dude you know
like and and and I get that too you know
what I mean it was a you're just jealous
but I I at least know the difference
between angry and jealous you know what
I mean so that yeah I'd say envious
sometimes or some things but I don't I
don't think I'm the type that gets
jealous cuz I know what jealousy looks
like and it's like thank the guy who has
a presidency mm-hmm who's magged
someone's making more money than him
yeah and I'm gonna do something to bring
you down a peg listen I don't I'm he's
obsessed with Jeff pace obsessed with
Amazon because Jeff and this is what I
think owns the Washington Post we
success with somebody every other yeah
it's just one target one of his enemies
because the Washington Post is always
like doing expose he's not Trump well
Jeff Bezos is like that dude wants to
control the whole [ __ ] world
and you got to be real and he almost
done that motivated in a way well that's
that's Peter teal that's that's that
that's some next-level weirdness [ __ ]
look him up he's a [ __ ] real piece of
work okay actually he's gonna graph he's
gonna slide me a photograph no he's like
he's like he's like he's like bizarro
Elon Musk
Oh Dan said he wants co-founder of
PayPal yeah oh he's he's bizarro Elon
Musk he wants to build round utopians
fine
and he's got these big projects really
weird he's half of the he and apparently
I don't know this fact or not but he's
like he started to fund the whole Colgan
thing going full circle here he funded
that suit to get back at Gawker cuz
Gawker said some [ __ ] up [ __ ] about
him I love this just billion yeah yeah
you know that's one of my one of my
biggest fears in life is being in the
target of a billionaire who will sue me
forever we went through a lawsuit it's
the worst thing ever and it longs for so
long hydrogen atom or like tried to see
you know it was a colleague it no it
wasn't that helium came at you bro and
you had to change it to somebody to this
person
we D invented reactions no we won by the
way but it ended up costing like two
hundred thousand dollars and it took
like a like a year super stress you want
me to feel sorry for you but but what
I'm saying I know you're in losses it
wasn't cheap so if if somebody if [ __ ]
Jeff betas basis is like hey I want to
ruin this guy's life you can just sue me
for any dumb [ __ ] forever I understand
what does the universe trying to tell
everyone to just be nice to everyone
well it's just my fear that's that's how
we evolved lawsuits do we would all have
diseases and deformities and [ __ ]
weird [ __ ] if that's the way the
universe works but it doesn't so there
will be lawsuits yeah yeah yeah well
speaking of lawsuits so you were in a
real classic classic it was lawsuits
actually there's new class people study
the ship mas because it gets how did
that one pan out um with Disney over the
years you know what I'd [ __ ] I gotta be
real careful you can't see this one I
can't say how it like what the the
settlement terms were but it was settled
you guys it was amicable although that's
what they say about everything yes yeah
well but that's what
we're only allowed to you know I said
something then boom we'd be back find
that [ __ ] right where we were what loss
is that we're one of we're one of three
people in the history of Buenavista to
ever walk out unscathed
dude destiny lawyers are terrifying yeah
if there are parts of Disney that show
to other parts of disease we what's
nobody wins I love Disney they've got
this big happy smiley faces fireworks in
a castle and underneath is just lawyers
lawyers okay but I love this phrase it
we we separated amicably is what they
would say what it could mean like yeah I
had to sacrifice I had to throw my
firstborn into a volcano
it ended amicably it's we're good we're
all good but even more interesting we're
broken yeah yeah John Brown organic but
the omelet is tasty um even more
interesting to me personally than that
one is the lawsuit over mailing Tain's
Oh calm also incomplete and I believe oh
is it concluded okay
and very very amicably a lot so
everyone's feeling great lots of
laughter bowls dolls were had and though
that concludes that conversation about
lawsuits are you I mean if you ever want
to gauge a companies like intent and and
resources to do it just find out what
they're worth and then don't step to it
and then just omit yeah right what were
you saying all right do you have any
lawsuits ongoing right now you're
involved in probably no no no I'm like
honestly like III want to avoid them as
much as the next guy I like you know
it's funny is they are and then and some
of them are just entertaining in the
fact that you know if I was richer I
maybe find them funny well I mean okay
no no no just think of it as a part of
business you don't I mean hire and it's
not a part of every business but it is a
part of many business yes where they it
is where conflict arises and there was
no waiting you have to be very conscious
of how these things work and how to you
know mitigate
things and get through that process so
that when [ __ ] really [ __ ] hits the
fan you're better prepare for that you
know you know what you can and cannot
[ __ ] do I mean it's not like we have
to go around and [ __ ] it employing
people for you know 30 cents a [ __ ]
hour not to know minimum wage laws right
but like you know scale that up to you
know technical rights and and you know
intellectual property rights and music
law and all that stuff like [ __ ] my
lawyer tells me all the [ __ ] time she
does I dude you literally write the bar
like right now and you would be fine you
know you don't have to because you're
[ __ ] doing all these other things but
you know you want to be a music lawyer
you're good to go
you do not to say that you know that oh
the best advice I'd ever give a musician
is be a lawyer
that's sad you know no matter being it
for as long as you have you it becomes a
machine you understand all the working
components and and and things that come
to impede that machine and how to fix it
it's just like being an auto mechanic
they don't auto mechanics aren't great
model mechanics because they just never
had to fix a [ __ ] car mm-hmm you got
to know what breaks them and and how to
fix them better you know and so that
they don't get broken again right
everybody I hope they nobody go through
a lot no no I wouldn't wish it on anyone
and I don't proactively seek them out
unless there is you know something to be
had like one one and and there are I've
actually been in more lawsuits that
weren't even [ __ ] lawsuits that
everyone seems to think there was one
being the suicide boys some rap band
from Atlanta literally verbatim took a
song of mine and rapped on it hmm and
then put it out like didn't sell a
million copies or whatever and then they
put it out now all we did we send a C
and D which is common saying don't use
while we appreciate your effort yeah I
would prefer you not to monetize my work
and take it off right and the internet
freaked out and I'm wondering now okay
who is more stupid someone who takes
someone else's work and raps on it and
then just doesn't give me credit for it
publishes it or the people that think
that that's normal fine that's fine
everyone's like you know why did you do
why did you sue them well yeah well we
didn't sue them it's not worth and you
gotta pay for their whole life up if you
want it done no no well yeah yeah yeah
you sure if did it so bored I mean I
bored but you know it's just like
literally a one-page letter that says
please not please stop yeah and then
that's it and it's if they ignore the
integral [ __ ] you and then they sell it
on iTunes and it's like okay [ __ ] just
got real
yeah you know and then then it gets
crazy but it never gets that point cool
well I recently put a picture of me up
with a bunch of [ __ ] satanic imagery
and I think yeah they got a hard-on for
me too I don't know but um and and then
because it's my photograph of not a
photograph of me but one that I actually
own the image rights to right we said
take that down that's my image you can't
just do that your bottom-feeding lawyer
should know basic copyright law and then
they were forced to take it down and
then all of a sudden is deadmau5 sues
karela the bag yeah well I didn't sue
them I just told him to do something I
didn't have to yeah I mean it would have
been ugly as [ __ ] afterwards but they
didn't have to we suggest things and
point out obvious [ __ ] but we don't
go looking for [ __ ] I don't go taking
down videos of people uploading my music
on the YouTube channel which is kind of
like an AIDS fast right now of everybody
just doing that but eh you know that's
how the culture is I accept you know
like I'm not mmm-hmm right you know
that's just just that is so weird so let
me let me wrap it up here we have a
ceremony about how we end these usually
is it start with a CNN with an a/c and
with a no can we get another so come on
in this has been like long in when they
bring me my rider on stage when I was
talking in the twitch thing they just
bring the whole six-pack oh you know
they
don't bring him piecemeal come on bring
the sake of Christ's sake no no my
cutoff this is number three after seven
I was joking we're gonna have a bowl
with of M&Ms without the brown ones here
for you that's not a me joke that's it's
a needy artists joke no that's actually
a very specific artist who is that I
don't remember it was like I don't
remember who it's an old rock band um
yeah
van Halen or something I don't know what
do I know
so there you still trying to think of
that what what would it been I don't
know it's some movie so we and
irrelevant
apparently I have I've got I got people
people dance said Led Zeppelin and said
van Halen I'm one of the two lead Halen
well that Island those guys man I love
that oh it is y'all look at me like I'm
so what's the thing yeah so first of all
if you don't have a story it's fine but
we like to ask our guests at the end of
our shows if they have any ghost stories
or paranormal experiences UFO encounters
or any funky kind of unexplainable thing
and just for reference I don't I'm not a
believer I don't have any stories so
don't feel bad if you don't and I
thought that we would appropriately
named this ghosts and stuff story got
him well I don't know it's not really a
ghost story but he was still pretty
creepy that were key stories are buki
yeah it's kind of dumb and no one's
gonna believe me but it actually
happened um yeah that's all through it
and then if I can actually think of
something paranormal because I don't
believe anything that [ __ ] yeah he
needed and that's that's why it was a
joke because actually ghost us up
derives from like I wanted to make a
vacuum cleaner that detected ghosts that
played a MIDI file was just some stupid
joke but um anyway
me and my agent Joel Zimmerman who shows
the same name we were talking about the
deadmau5 thing and all this [ __ ] and
then like this is like before ghosts and
stuff so I was like when I was just
Jules ermine and and and I was talking
to Joey we were going like over artists
kind of marketing stuff and we're
walking down the street like middle of
the [ __ ] night like downtown Toronto
and and he's he was asking me about
deadmau5 and I was trying to tell him
the [ __ ] story and I'll [ __ ] nice
what I got right this actually happened
and then right nobody believes me but
right [ __ ] as soon as we were like in
the middle of the conversation a [ __ ]
cat walked by with a mouse in its mouth
and dropped it off like right in front
of us and just disappeared and like no
I'm gay and I know everyone's like all
this [ __ ] but I swear to god you can
ask troll he will swear to it and is it
suspicious that the only other dude who
can vouch for this story is that's good
I love that that's that qualifies did
you want to get real dark yes yeah this
is the [ __ ] up thing this is this is
like some weird fate [ __ ] I was I think
it was about seven years ago I was on my
way out of Ibiza to go to somewhere else
in Europe and me and my tour manager
Paul McRae we're basically the way you
go to babysit you don't go from like
well you could now from Heathrow over
there but you had to hop from Madrid so
we would fly to Madrid go to Ibiza party
show Madrid Heathrow then wherever else
so we had a show I can't remember where
it was um like after the Ibiza one so we
had to really like rush to get our
connection in Madrid and then fly out
elsewhere and we get to the airport
where like about 15 minutes before the
next plane is now if you ever been the
the airport in Madrid it's like it's
like O'Hare it's like crazy long in our
flight that God in was way at the front
like that we were going to get on which
way pian and you know escalators no
trains we had to [ __ ] literally run
to make that [ __ ] flight and it was
like kind of a big deal of a show that
there's just no way we could [ __ ] missus
so let's [ __ ] just book it [ __ ] it I
swear to god I've never run so fast in
my life because like literally a lot of
money was on the line and then we get to
the [ __ ] thing they're like doing the
closed door thing and we're like [ __ ]
serious they were like ab like I mean if
you were like a minute you know we could
let you on but we've literally pulled
the [ __ ] thing off the flight and it
was like Spanair so they had pulled the
gate off the [ __ ] thing and we're
like oh [ __ ] okay well let's start
calling around see if we can find
something like private options all [ __ ]
and so we're just kind of [ __ ] laying
around in there waiting for like some
kind of option to help flight goes up
[ __ ] not even [ __ ] like about 300
feet off the runway plane crashes
everyone on board dies it was that span
airflow we just [ __ ] missed that
flight and and there were there was
about me about 800 to a thousand people
like all like in the airport nobody made
a [ __ ] sound it was the creepiest
[ __ ] [ __ ] and everyone was like you
could see you could hear it it was right
outside the airport uh well no it was
like half a mile out so you couldn't see
her no we saw the smoke and the
explosion Elijah cuz it went up I don't
know the details on it but it went up
and it [ __ ] landed flat and [ __ ]
apparently no one [ __ ] survived that
but we had just barely missed that
[ __ ] flight and then the next flight
we got on like to get us out like it was
the freakiest [ __ ] thing I mean I'm a
numbers dude so like I thought it was
fine like just here two planes oh and I
don't know you know but like so everyone
on that flight going out everyone was
like praying and [ __ ] it was so
surreal man but we were like 16 minutes
how do you how do you insane story hey
if that's just the universe man you know
like I I don't I might not ever never
gonna fly again you know like that's
just
it's just [ __ ] weird that we just
barely narrowly missed him crazy that is
that is truly truly incredible and you
know not like you know what I mean crazy
in some alternate universe you know what
I mean yeah but like how do you like in
a way just did you feel like some kind
of divine intervention oh just so my god
I do it like how do you explain that
it's just on pure chance
I can't yeah mm-hmm just [ __ ] dude look
at the universe how [ __ ] random [ __ ]
I don't mean the universe like the
universal sense I mean like space and
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] some quasar going off
like [ __ ] 200 light years away who's
gonna wipe us out you know any or
whatever you know like this is so
chaotic and we well past our
understanding that I don't want to go
ahead and reserve this little
narrow-minded spot to a great controller
you know that just knows what
everything's doing and and it's all
supposed to be this way I'm like that's
a mind [ __ ] them yes Wow yeah how was
the show oh I don't know like I landed
on a light one anything we had some
other shitty DJ that I hate makes
generic EDM Dillon Francis was that real
or was out no he's a nice guy as a
person right he's [ __ ] garbage hot
garbage but I love him you selfie above
you he should stop [ __ ] DJing and be
a goddamn like comedian or TV show host
or something but let him do what he want
anyway me and him were in Vegas and I
had set a budget because I was flying
out that day to go back to Canada so in
Canada the law is you can't you have to
declare anything over $10,000 right okay
we're gonna go play some [ __ ]
blackjack and I'm gonna make exactly
$10,000 I'm gonna buy a coffee and
that'll be under and I'm gonna take that
in I don't have to declare it I used to
do that a lot I used to gamble at
[ __ ] win I'd come home with 500
[ __ ] grand and I'd have to declare it
and they sit there and they count it
like a promise accident no oh
you want to count it yeah just for the
record okay because paper trail right
right that's all that's where that sorry
just give me a minute here sidetrack um
a guy who did some big Cisco buyout of
his shares or something like that
smuggled in two million in cash or
something in a candidate didn't declare
it hand it in to gym bags brought the
gym bags off one of my good friends is
like head of [ __ ] immigration or
whatever in Toronto Pearson and they
took the the suitcases on went found you
know two million dollars in cash there
and they literally find him huge huge
huge huge [ __ ] mines may be possible
jail time I'll [ __ ] all he had to do was
declare it right that's it and they
would have just said alright sir fine
you know we just want to know you know
like and then he got [ __ ] so he tells
me doesn't matter how much you bring
just [ __ ] declare right yeah and I'm
like okay so anyway I was a big gambler
and all a [ __ ] and then I was doing the
whole Big Shot thing with Dylan and we
go to blackjack and five minutes I win
like 10 grand I'm like [ __ ] awesome
right and no actually I won like 11
grand or something stupid right and
how's like [ __ ] I got an extra thousand
right and Dylan's like will school play
[ __ ] roulette I'm like alright fine
so I just put thousand dollars on number
five [ __ ] right and then if it hits
it then holy [ __ ] but if it doesn't then
[ __ ] whatever it's gone I don't have
to worry about I didn't want it anyway
okay so they spin the wheel put the
[ __ ] ball in and then Dylan's looking
at my [ __ ] [ __ ]
and then he grabs my chips and puts it
on the [ __ ] like the weirdest like
the green thing the one that's like the
one in 32 right I was like [ __ ] he doing
in the the guy at the Volvo dealer the
ball guys like Oh bro you know you can't
do that and then it goes like that's his
chips you know if he wants to move that
he'll move it kind of thing and then
Dylan's like oh sorry you know because
kind of a noob and I was like yeah
whatever it's cool just just don't do
that and I'm from green I'm like dude
you just touch my [ __ ] [ __ ] and by
time we stopped [ __ ] arguing about it
the [ __ ] thing lands on green I swear
to God the one payout would have paid me
out like about 400 [ __ ] grand on the
thousand dollars
now it landed on the one where Dylan
moved it to I was like you I wanted to
beat the [ __ ] out he was like see that
would have been sweet to declare that
yeah but now all that left the declare
is that his musics garbage and I hate
him mmm well thank you so much man for
coming in sitting with us yeah thanks
for the beers thank you thanks for
sharing your stories and everything and
we really appreciate it looking forward
to the new album it's really exciting
hope you have a great time there mm-hmm
yeah thanks for having me I didn't know
what to expect
I feel better didn't have to talk about
yeah deadly gnarly we should catch up up
G game sometime should that be good soon
as they fix it the game works
I'm all for it we were just talking
about how we wish we wish pub she was
fortnight servers take out the court
gets the say cup take out the forts
you've got a great gal VP for I had no
building yeah 1v1 me love it won't be
one we fortnight no buildings that's
where the real battlegrounds go down
guys thank you so much for watching um
what's up next week Dan you know you my
shut damn thing is closed for Christ's
sake it's closed we got Bobby Lee next
Friday
Bob oh come on come on it's falling
apart at the end
Bobby Lee the comedian yeah I love him
yeah sorry cool he apparently Dylan my
son hi oh are you guys friends or no I
met him once very briefly but I wanna
catch his show more often than he
probably thinks at the Comedy Store
oh cool I'll let him know so I my
computer is gonna blow up right now okay
and there's also a Tuesday episode every
time I click on this all right Tuesday
we've got DJ Doug Pound who is one of my
favorite comedians she worked with Tim
and Eric is a great and funny guy Friday
we've gotten to body Lee don't miss that
[ __ ] all right guys have a great weekend
god bless you appreciate you wish you
all the best and thank you once again
the deadmau5 George Zimmerman and the
new album is coming out the [ __ ] isn't
sure but I said you said George
Zimmerman because that's a guy in
Florida who killed a dude you idiots you
idiot everything was fine and now you're
George Zimmerman guys you were supposed
to think about it
damn you were supposed to have cut it
already cut it just cut it